foreign
Jessica is in Billings Montana hi
Jessica welcome to the Ramsay show
hi Dave my husband and I have been on
your plan for about the last five years
me
have done 3B for the last two and we've
decided to go back to doing four we're
just feeling really discouraged and not
being able to afford a house where we we
are here in Montana and just feeling
like we're still years away even after
we've been saving for the last four and
I just wondered if you had any advice
for us
how much have you saved
we have a twenty thousand dollar
emergency fund and 47 500 in a down
payment fund
what's your household income
between my husband and I at 75 000 a
year you need to go buy a house
we tried we've been trying so we looked
at a house yesterday for 265 which is
really affordable for our area and
I know you recommend a 15-year loan um
but that seems Way Out Of Reach so on a
30 the payments would be between 17 and
1800 a month which is more like 35
percent of our take-home pay instead of
25. you're not discouraged you're
throwing a fit because you can't buy the
house you want that's not the same as
being discouraged
okay we haven't been able to have
anything lower than that yeah keep
looking you need to find a home that you
can afford that is a blessing don't buy
something that's a curse because you uh
because you didn't look hard enough I
mean sometimes this isn't a an adventure
this house hunting thing
um you don't have an unlimited budget
you make seventy thousand dollars a year
you have forty seven thousand dollars to
put down don't put your family into a
crisis just to become a homeowner but
also don't don't say home ownership's
Out Of Reach in Billings Montana it's
not
you can do this but you know it may not
be the house you saw yesterday and and
yeah I would do it on a 15-year fixed
where the payments no more than a fourth
of your take-home pay why because I want
you to be millionaires later and I don't
want this house to ride you I want you
to ride the house
Dave I
Sheila and I my wife and I did something
that's not really it's not in the baby
steps
um oh but we found ourselves in this
situation and tell me if this is crazy
we as a couple decided we are going to
do essentially a
another gazelle Sprint so that we can
afford this down payment of a house and
we decided just to lock things down in
the middle for a limited amount of time
I think we said nine months something
like that and we're just gonna work
bananas I'll take an extra job and I'm
gonna adjunct here I'm gonna do the and
let's just accelerate this process real
fast get this down payment so that we
can then move this thing along the only
thing that's not the baby steps there is
just we teach you to be intentional not
intense right and you said in order to
get the house I want I'm gonna I'm gonna
we're gonna we're gonna turn up the heat
yeah we're gonna go for it but and we
decided together it like yeah yeah both
of you work extra no vacations no eating
out and you go back to gazelle intensity
and you take your 47 and you make it 75
right and let's do this for six months
and let's just be bananas about it and
then it then we're gonna have no
problems yeah but you the the problem is
when you do a little bit of everything
nothing gets done that's right and so
you you start losing Death By A Thousand
Cuts then and that's what I'm afraid of
here uh and and so it's just
it is
um
it's not all Skittles and rainbows when
you go look at houses
no it's the worst because you always see
something you can't afford always we're
drawing a house plan to build next
summer
and um the uh the guy helping us with it
actually added the numbers wrong
accidentally
and so when we actually added them right
the house was like ridiculous or like
we're not doing that
and we can afford to do it whatever but
it's just like it's huge you know
there's someone just no we're not doing
that let's fix this so we've gone
through and cut the dadgum thing down
but it's it's depressing it hurts right
to go backward after you were up is
depressing and I could afford it right
so I have the choice but if you don't
have the choice and you've got to cut
down because it doesn't fit the budget
or it doesn't fit the situation it's
depressing yeah if you you know it's
don't go drive new cars if you're in
getting ready to buy a new one I used
one yeah because a new one of those you
know blow your dadgum mind and then you
can't you can't return you can't yeah
and don't fall in the Trap of a
frustration and frustration and
frustration if you're around a child
especially like a toddler you know they
get annoyed they get annoyed they get
annoyed and then they just hit something
or they just shove something over or
they bite somebody don't just go see a
house go see a house go see a house and
then just get so frustrated that you buy
something yeah because it's just the way
it is and you don't understand just walk
walk away yeah yeah that's what you back
up take a cold shower
get house fever I mean it's a it's a
real thing I I understand it's easy to
be oh listening to her I threw a temper
tantrum the other day I wanted to buy
something and again I can afford it
I have there was no reason on the planet
to buy it none zero except I just wanted
it and I that my temper tantrum Dave was
at me yeah you know I mean the grown-up
me was telling the kid me I can't do
this and the kid that's what we're doing
with this house plants so like the
grown-up me looked at that and went
that's just dumber than crap we're not
doing that and Sharon goes that's
ridiculous we're not doing that and I'm
going but I like it and I want it I want
it I want it I want it and yeah I mean
that's human freaking nature and if I
who teach this stuff every year for 30
years fall for it then Jessica in
Billings Montana you had permission to
fall for it too right but you've got to
fight the inner child do the next right
thing the one on the cereal aisle that
throws a fit and says I want it I want
it no call the wambulance take six jobs
build up your down payment or lower your
price point that you're looking at and
quit looking at houses you can't afford
and that's what you got to do it's a
pain in the butt this thing called
grown-up Phil